I am sick and tired of these efforts to privatize
a precious thing we need, public education.
I know we're not supposed to be saying hate,
our teachers taught us not to,
I hate the privatizers, I want to stop them.
Speaking recently before the country's largest
union
New York City Mayor Bill de Blasio came out
against the very concept of charter schools.
Too many Republicans but also too many Democrats
have been cozy with the charter schools
let's be blunt about it.
De Blasio's opinion as a fourth tier Democratic
presidential candidate doesn't matter much
but what's disturbing is the extent to which
his anti-charter animus
is rapidly becoming a core value in the Democratic
party.
As the head of the nation's largest school
system,
de Blasio's prejudices are also having a direct
impact on individual lives.
In New York City 123 thousand students out
of a public school system of 1.1 million
attend charter schools.
Unsurprisingly the mayor's remarks drew hot
fire from the hometown tabloids.
-snarled the New York Daily News, and-
the hostility that New York progressives,
especially white New York progressives,
have toward charters
is already taking its toll on poor minority
kids stuck in failing districts.
The state legislature last month
elected not to lift the cap on the number
of charters allowed in New York City
despite overwhelming demand from parents.
As local political personality and columnist
Errol Louis noted
in the 2017-18 school year,
about 59% of black students attending charters
passed the state math test
compared with only 25% in regular district
schools.
One charter school in the Bronx recently saw
every single one of its eighth graders
earn a perfect score on the state algebra
exam
despite being situated in the nations' poorest
congressional district.
Half of kids attending traditional public
schools in the same district failed the test.
53% of the charters' kids are African American,
38% are Latino,
81% are low income, free and reduced lunch,
and they're outscoring the traditional public
schools in every measurable dimension,
I understand where there are problems like,
you know,
there are 53 thousand people on this waiting
list and so forth
but there's nothing you can learn from them?
We again I say we partner with the ones that
share those values of inclusion
we work with them, best practices are shared
both ways.
I think there are some charter schools that
do the work,
are test prep factories,
I think there are some charter schools that
are exclusionary
and that goes against everything I believe
in.
Former Congressman Beto O'Rourke,
who used to be a full-throated supporter of
charters,
was the only one of the ten candidates at
the same teachers union conference
brave enough to suggest even that there is
a place for public nonprofit charter schools.
But Beto quickly got to the but.
But private charter schools and voucher programs,
not a single dime of my administration will
go to them.
What used to be a fairly mainstream democratic
idea,
championed by the likes of Barack Obama, Joe
Biden
and pre-presidential campaign Senator Corey
Booker
has now become something candidates feel like
they need to furiously backpedal from
and according to one recent survey,
those reformist tendencies are not likely
to be seen again from a democrat anytime soon.
Bill de Blasio's career
has been marked by the extent to which he's
willing to sell out his constituents,
in this case poor kids in failing schools,
in order to advance his own political career.
Sadly that puts him in the mainstream of the
modern democratic party.